-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show" everyone.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well guys,
last night in Chicago,
President Biden
spoke at a fundraiser,
and he decided to kick it off
with a shout-out
to his home state of Delaware.
Let's see how that went.
-Is Delaware in the house?
Anybody from Delaware?
[ Light cheering ]
Holler loudly, man.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the equivalent of
a drummer tossing his drumsticks
into the crowd and then hearing
them hit the ground like,
"Click, click, click."
[ Drumsticks clack ]
Yeah, exactly.
[ As Biden ]
Is Delaware in the...
[ Normal voice ]
Is Delaware in the house?
-Oh!
-Who is he? DJ Jazzy Scooter?
But today,
Biden was back in Washington,
where he hosted a -- co-hosted
a virtual COVID summit.
Yep. And The fact that
the summit was held virtually
pretty much tells you
how we're doing
in the fight against COVID.
The U.S. co-hosted a summit with
Germany, Indonesia, Senegal,
and Belize.
Good, all the heavy hitters
are in on this.
But Biden is serious about
tackling the pandemic.
That's why, today, he announced
the new head of his
COVID task force, Patti LuPone.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
-Hey, listen to this guys.
Moderna has fired their new CFO
after just one day on the job.
Yep, they thought
he was Moderna quality,
but it turns out he was more of
Johnson & Johnson material.
Fired on day one.
He basically walked in with
a box of his things
and just turned around
and walked out.
At his farewell party,
he was like,
"I really enjoyed the 27 minutes
I spent with all of you."
Apparently, the boss walked in
on him lying back in his chair,
tossing syringes up, trying to
get them stuck in the ceiling.
His LinkedIn profile now says,
"Start date: May 9, 2022.
End date: lunchtime."
Hey, guys, this is big.
Astronomers just revealed
the first image of a black hole,
the black hole
in the center of our galaxy.
Look at this. Check this out.
-Ooh!
-Yeah. That's either a black
hole or someone ate a Cheeto
and touched the telescope lens.
Well, guys, it's been a rough
week for the stock market,
and I saw that Apple's stock
is down almost 10%.
Yeah, they're getting hit hard,
so I thought maybe I'd
check in with Siri
to see how it's going.
Hey, Siri, are you there?
-Why don't you go ask
that bitch Alexa.
-Whoa! Indeed!
-Caught you at a bad time.
-Wow!
-Meanwhile, I read that
Party City's stock has crashed
because they had to
pay so much more
for the helium
in their balloons.
Yeah. We actually have footage
of the meeting
they had earlier today.
Look at this.
-[ High-pitched ]
Dale, have you seen
the latest revenue projections?
-[ High-pitched ] I have, Doug.
And even though this is
Party City,
these numbers do not
make me want to party.
-Yep. This is what happens to
your business with inflation.
-We knew this could happen with
the supply chain.
Now, I was hoping
we could squeak by.
-Well, it was a good run
while it lasted.
[ Hissing ]
[ Squeaking ]
[ Hissing stops ]
-[ Deeply ]
I'm gonna miss you, bro.
-[ Deeply ] You too.
John, don't!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's --
-It's not hydrogen.
-What don't you understand?
-Two guys are talking.
-That's understandable.
-Right. Both in blond wigs.
-No, no, no, that's real hair.
-Oh, that's real hair, okay.
And then they have helium on,
so they're talking high.
-It's Party City, dude!
-Then we cut to them.
Apparently,
their voices are low.
And helium, a non-flammable gas,
burst into flame.
That's all. That's all.
I love it. I love it.
110, man. I'll be honest, 110.
-Who knows what else
is in that office?
-Right. No one else is gonna --
It's Party City, man.
-Yeah, it's not
going well over there.
-No, not well at all.
-Not well at all.
Some more business news, guys.
Nike has accused
the retail website StockX
of selling counterfeit versions
of their shoes.
-What?!
-Ooh!
-Yep. Apparently,
people were angry
that they dropped 300 bucks on
a pair of Air Gordons.
Yeah, counterfeit Nikes.
StockX was like,
"If you have a problem,
talk to our brand ambassador,
LeJron Brames."
LeJron?
-"Yes."
-Meanwhile, Skechers is like,
"How come no one ever
counterfeits us?"
You know who else sells
counterfeit Nikes?
Adidas.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, I said it.
Snap!
-Snap! Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Deeply ]
"I'm going to miss you, dude."
[ Normal voice ] Hey,
I read that several wineries
are now struggling due to
rising cost in cork shortages.
Well, we asked a few
wine vintners about the issues,
and here's what they had to say.
First up, the vintner of
this wine said...
Next vintner
of this next wine said...
And, finally, the vintner of the
Barefoot Wine said...
I'm happy for them.
Good for them.
-Good for them.
-They're killing it.
Some more entertainment news.
A lot of fans are theorizing
that, this Friday,
Taylor Swift is going to drop
"1989 (Taylor's version),"
and could also release...
[ Crowd cheers ]
...could also release "Speak Now
(Taylor's version)"
on the same day.
-Yeah, but how do you know that?
Isn't that just a rumor?
-[ Scoffs ] I mean, the clues
are everywhere, Tariq.
-What clues?
-Okay, so, in Taylor's
last music video,
for "Red (Taylor's version)"
bonus track,
"I Bet You Think It's About Me,"
there's a wedding cake.
And on the cake,
there are numbers 13 and 26.
You follow?
-Yeah, no.
-"Red (Taylor's version)" was
Taylor's most recent re-release.
13 is Taylor's favorite number,
and this Friday, May 13th,
is 26 weeks from
the release date of
"Red (Taylor's version)."
-Okay, well, I guess --
-Also, if you look at
Taylor's official store,
signed CD copies of
"Fearless (Taylor's version)"
are currently on sale
for $19.89.
Get it? 1989, 1989!
-Alright, well,
then you're probably --
-But, also,
"Red (Taylor's version)"
was listed on sale on her store
for $20.10 in purple text.
-And that means what?
-Are you even listening?
The original "Speak Now"
was released in 2010.
On the cover of that album,
she's wearing a purple dress.
Purple, 2010, $20.10!
And six days ago, after dropping
her newest single,
"This love (Taylor's version),"
which is a song
originally from "1989,"
she wrote on Instagram
that she
"Reliving the 1989 tour."
But she also put out
a bunch of merch called
"The Old Taylor Collection"
that features clothes
referencing both "1989"
and "Speak Now."
I mean,
it can't be any more obvious.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know you're
47 years old, right?
-Yeah, but I'm 47,
Jimmy's version.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He said it.
-Yeah, I said it.
Hey, guys, I saw that
the Mega Millions lottery
had to suspend payments for
an $86 million jackpot
because of
a pretty costly mistake
during Tuesday's drawing.
Listen to this.
-If you bought
a Mega Millions ticket
for Tuesday's drawing,
you may want to check
your numbers again.
Mega Millions says the host
called out the wrong number
for the Mega Ball
during the live drawing.
He said it was a 6,
when it was actually a 9.
[ AUDIENCE "Oohs" ]
-I feel like the only thing
that job requires is
knowing the difference
between 6s and 9s.
"Can you hold a Ping-Pong ball?"
-"No."
-"I can't."
Alright, we'll make it easy.
We'll just put
it in a plastic tube.
"That's all I can do."
-9.
-Yeah.
The guy who thought
he won went to his boss like,
"First, I'd like to apologize
for what I suggested you
do to yourself."
Well, this is wild.
A woman in Indiana
was having a tree removed
from her backyard,
when something went wrong.
Look at this.
-Oh!
-Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-Did they really just ask if
that's supposed to happen?
The truck driver was like,
"Uh, yeah, all good.
Yeah, everything as planned.
That's perfect.
Yeah, that's normal."
That's supposed to happen.
Removing a tree should look like
the opening scene of
a "Fast and Furious" movie.
And, finally, it's time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags," guys.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since we're headed
into prom season,
I sent out the hashtag
"#PromFail,"
and I asked you guys to share
some funny or weird things
that happened at your prom.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#PromFail tweets from you guys.
This first one is from
@jend7512. She says...
-Sounds cool.
-That's cool.
-Next one's from
@AlliAlliAlli33.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-"Boop!"
-This next one is
from @Boho-Beau. She says...
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Use a condiment, everybody.
Use a condiment.
-Yeah. No.
[ Laughter ]
-Next one is from
@claydoughrocks. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good joke. Why?
-Oh, why? Why?
Why would they do that?
-This next one is from
@SaiyanaBrief. She says...
-Oh.
-Hm.
Wow. That one just --
-Kind of like bragging.
-Yeah. People did not
enjoy that --
-I don't think they --
I don't think they liked that.
-I think the audience
loved that one.
-You think so? Do you really?
Oh, because you think they were
rapt with attention.
They didn't make any noise.
So they're like --
-Yeah, they took it.
They go like...
-They took it in.
-Yeah.
-Then they went, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
"She still has her $200 dress."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That's really a PromWin.
-Yeah, not a PromFail.
-With all these other losers
with their puffy dresses.
-"I can relate to it.
I can relate to it
because I had to buy
that expensive dress,
and I kept that dress, but
you can never wear it again."
-Right. But she still has
her $200 dress.
-She was just saying.
-And flaunting it
in the faces...
-She's just saying,
like, as a joke.
-You think it was a joke.
-She doesn't really --
-But don't jokes elicit laughter
from people?
[ Laughter ]
Like, when I was --
I was listening --
-Not necessarily.
Not necessarily.
You heard me when --
-I heard you say it,
and then I heard the audience,
my friends in the audience,
not respond at all,
'cause they were going like...
"Hmm."
I wish -- Can we replay that?
Can we replay that?
-No, no, I don't want
to replay it.
-Let's just see it.
Let's just see it real quick.
-SayanaBrief. She says...
-Ohh.
-Hmm.
Wow. That one just --
-Kind of like bragging.
[ Laughter ]
I heard a couple "ohhs."
"Ohh."
-It wasn't complete silence.
-No, it was not
complete silence.
It was like, "Ohh."
-Anyone here from Delaware?
-Yeah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go. I heard that.
Welcome.
This last one here
is from @lmhksu. She says...
Look at this. Look at --
Zoom in. Hey!
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of my favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.